j'avais 17 ans donc en lycée quand on va
aller à expliqué aussi que ça se passe
et genre se moquer de moi à l'école
parce que j'étais différent je cherchais
avant tout un métier où je pouvais
gagner ma vie et vivre donc j'ai fait
pas mal de métiers plomberie ça doit en
restauration en fait j'ai fait partout
et j'ai eu que des refus et tu as passé
combien
j'ai battu record du monde entretien
d'embauche en record j'ai eu certains
qui m'ont accès pour essai et qui vont
pas bien appris suite ensuite mais ce
qui se passe c'est que je précisais à
certains moments quand on me demandait
que j'étais autiste asperger je vais
préciser que j'avais droit à une RQTH
qui est normalement toute bénef puisque
c'est une une aide financière pour
l'entreprise et même ça c'était pas
suffisant pour qu'il m'accepte qu'est-ce
qu'il te disais il y en a qui voulait
pas de moi simplement
bonjour je m'appelle Samy Vincent je
suis trépied et depuis quelques mois
maintenant ce que vous voyez autour de
moi c'est ma camionnette c'est là où je
travaille et on tache c'est que je suis
mon propos patron quand j'étais embauché
en tant que tourneur de Crète dans une
boulangerie et ma licencié je me suis
dit plutôt que d'avoir refaire des
recherches d'emploi que je m'en suis
déjà fait une bonne santé minimum
que je débrouillerai
mon rythme était plutôt bien mais il y
en avait pour des heures de travail je
commençais à 5h je suis prof finir à 13h
d'après-midi
qu'est-ce que ça sera bon je vais
prendre comme la dernière phone chocolat
maison s'il vous plaît
encore peut-être
[Musique]
à chercher parce que les démarches
administratives j'ai fait beaucoup de
valeur je suis passé par un organisme
qui devait m'aider à trouver du travail
et cet organisme au lieu de ça vous
voyez un message tous les 6 mois pour me
demander où j'en étais pour une aide
c'est pas vraiment eu très très
utile je m'attendais à quelque chose
d'un peu plus
d'un peu plus m'organisé la France de ce
côté-là beaucoup de retard sur d'autres
pays où on connaît déjà l'autisme on
sait déjà comment prendre en charge et
venir en aide au début j'étais un peu en
colère mais vous savez après avec le
recul on se dit que
c'était peut-être pas pour ça que
j'étais destiné
que j'ai décidé à autre chose la crêpe
pas dedans
monsieur
je vis comme une grande force et autisme
si je dois borné tant que j'ai pas
obtenu ce que je veux je suis comme ma
mère je vais jusqu'au bout de mes rêves
c'était vraiment mouvementé mais
finalement j'y suis arrivé
voyez
me donne bon appétit je vais vous
préparer les crêpes non je fais des
efforts je sais plus en contact avec les
autres mais bien sûr quand je suis en
privé je suis plus dans ma tour d'ivoire
quoi
mais oui je fais des efforts tous les
jours pour être plus social et puis
j'entends autiste je suis comme une
véritable éponge émotionnelle donc si je
suis dans un environnement stressant
entre bruit trop de trop de
félicitations et tout je peux vite vite
être
[Musique]
surcharge un message pour les autistes
qui comme moi ont beaucoup de mal dans
le milieu je leur dis accrochez vous à
vos rêves faites en sorte de persévrier
parce que vous trouverez toujours des
gens pour refuser un emploi ou pour
mettre en travers de vos rêves donc
accrochez-vous car c'est gris et ne vous
laissez pas démonter
que serait la Bretagne sans beurre
[Musique]